economía aquí en directo América edición
nocturna está con nosotros en el estudio
Daniela Blandón Daniela muy buenas
noches comenzamos hablando de las
diferentes bolsas del mundo que
recobraron el nerviosismo después de esa
compra del First Bank así de Santiago
muy buenas noches os vamos a comenzar
entonces a ver cómo les fue a estos
mercados financieros Wall Street encerró
convertidas de más del 1% arrastrado por
el sector financiero que precisamente
renovó estos temores sobre la salud de
la banca regional además de la
energético tras una fuerte caída de casi
el 5% en el precio del petróleo todo
esto ocurre en la víspera de conocer la
decisión de la reserva Federal sobre
tasas de interés que se va a conocer
mañana iniciaron la reunión hoy en
Europa las bolsas también se tiñeron de
rojo después de que se conociera una
encuesta del Banco Central europeo que
reveló que los bancos de la zona Euro
están cerrando los grifos del crédito
esto sumado que finalmente está cayendo
la inflación subyacente que recordemos
es la que excluye ítems muy volátiles
con la energía y los alimentos le da
combustible a la esperanza de que haya
un aumento menor en la tasa de interés
del Banco Central su reunión es a
finales de esta semana y en América
Latina las bolsas cerraron mixtas Aunque
Sao Paulo registró un fuerte descenso en
medio de todas las expectativa sobre lo
que va a decidir la fe pasemos ahora a
hablar de un sector específico en
Estados Unidos los bancos medianos y los
bancos más pequeños de este país fueron
los grandes damnificados de la jornada
de hoy entonces comenzamos por el propio
First cuya acción que perdió más del 97%
de valor en las últimas semanas fue
suspendida hoy por la bolsa de Nueva
York y comenzó el proceso para retirar
su nombre de la lista de empresas
cotizadas esto después de que la entidad
fuera intervenida por las autoridades y
vendida después a JP Morgan Case el
banco más grande de Estados Unidos este
nuevo capítulo en la crisis de confianza
en la bolsa y en la banca
particularmente agitó a los demás bancos
sobre todo los pequeños y medianos la
acción de que ocupa el puesto 53 entre
los bancos más grandes o pequeños en
este caso cayó más del 27% también se
veían caídas drásticas Aunque Menores en
Western unions el banco número 40 y key
corp vigésimo en la lista por activos
otros como comerica y sino bus tuvieron
pérdidas similares y hablamos de uno de
los temas que avanzamos en los titulares
del programa La huelga del libretistas
de Hollywood comenzó a afectar al
público cuéntenos pues se trata del
primer paro en 15 años lo que afectará
sin duda la programación de series
películas y otros espectáculos unos más
que otros el gremio de escritores de
América que representa unos 11.500
libretistas dijo que la huelga durará el
tiempo que tenga que durar después de
que no se llegará a un acuerdo sobre
ajuste de salarios con compañías Como
por ejemplo Disney y Netflix el
argumento Cuál es pues que con el auge
del streaming que tienen trabajos por
menos tiempo Y peor pagados
el presidente biden es un firme
partidario del derecho a la huelga por
parte de los trabajadores él ha
trabajado para reforzar los derechos de
los trabajadores incluso mediante el
nombramiento de un fuerte equipo de
liderazgo en la junta Nacional de
relaciones laborales y a través de sus
esfuerzos para promover la ley Pro
protección del derecho a organizarse
nuevamente alentamos a ambas partes a
permanecer en la mesa pero siempre somos
muy conscientes
cambiamos de tema hablemos ahora de los
jefes de Google meta y Spotify que van a
ser interrogados en Brasil Qué pasó pues
que la Corte Suprema de ese país ordenó
que la policía interrogue en un plazo de
cinco días a los presidentes o sus
equivalentes de estos gigantes
tecnológicos la razón Cuál es que las
autoridades sospechan que se está
impulsando una campaña contra un
proyecto de ley que busca combatir la
desinformación en internet en particular
endurecer el control a las redes
sociales la polémica surgió a partir de
artículo que Google fijó en la versión
brasileña de su buscador titulado el
proyecto de ley de las fake news puede
aumentar la confusión sobre lo que es
verdad o mentira en Brasil Pues esta
publicación fue firmada por el propio
director de relaciones gubernamentales y
políticas públicas de esta empresa
Marcelo la cerda y expone una serie de
objeciones contra el mismo lo cierto Es
que la cámara de diputados ya sea lista
para votarlo esta misma semana y para el
cierre la cifra del día pues 2700
millones de dólares Este es el monto en
que logró reducir su deuda la
multinacional de productos de belleza
revlón que acaba de anunciar la salida
de la bancarrota esa empresa que lleva
más de 90 años vendiendo lápices
labiales esmaltes y otros productos se
inició el proceso de reorganización de
sus deudas hace menos de un año cuando
acumulaba deudas de más de 3.500
millones de dólares esto que no le
permitía pagarles a sus principales
proveedores ahora sus prestamistas
quedaron con la propiedad de la compañía
que dice que ya está muy sana
económicamente hablar Muchas gracias
Daniela por esta actualización del mundo
de la economía a continuación el debate
hacemos
énfasis en Afganistán
[Música]